aujourd'hui on parle de chez lui on
parle d'un nouveau smartphone le mil
neuf light j'en ai déjà parlé de la
présentation mais avant toute chose on
va parler de sécurité
je vous ramène en france on va parler de
sécuriser votre box internet
et croyez moi c'est extrêmement
important
[Musique]
la vidéo d'aujourd'hui est réalisé en
partenariat avec notre vie pn pour vous
parler de sécurité par rapport à votre
connexion internet
je sais pas si vous le savez sais pas si
vous savez comment ça marche pas si vous
êtes sensibilisé aux questions de
sécurité notamment quand vous avez vous
connecter à internet il faut savoir que
lorsque vous vous connectez vous
connectez vous de votre ordinateur ou de
votre téléphone directement à votre
fournisseur d'accès et ensuite aux sites
distants et en fait faut savoir que vous
donnez ne sont pas sécurisées votre
faute d'accès en gros c'est où vous
allez c'est ce que vous faites
et lorsque vous êtes connecté a dit wii
fit public vous soyez dans un hack d'eau
par exemple un hôtel un aéroport un
train ou n'importe quel lieu public et
alors là toutes les personnes connectées
peuvent si elles savent faire
intercepter vos données et là il faut
quand même dire que c'est un sujet qui
est très sensible d'où l'intérêt d'avoir
un vpn qui va venir en crypté tout ça en
gros l'idée c'est que vous vous
connectez au vpn le vpn va changer votre
adresse ip va tout en crypté en plus
noir des peines en crypte deux fois ce
qui fait que vous donnez ne peuvent plus
être vus vous êtes tranquilles sécurisé
protégé et ça c'est hyper important
bien évidemment la solution de dordogne
fonctionne aussi bien sur pc mac que sur
ios et android vous avez une application
à télécharger pour venir l'essayer vous
avez cette journée c'est gratuit l'appli
est très facile à utiliser vos disciples
ont su connectés j'ai ici accès à tous
les serveurs je peux choisir mon pays le
serveur voir où est ce que je me
connectais quel endroit dans l'eau je
suis là je suis connecté en france aussi
m mes serveurs en favori et soyez
tranquille ça marche
vachement bien vous avez plus de 5500
serveurs dont plus de 300 pays vous
pouvez bien évidemment sécuriser vos
données mais en plus vous connecter à
netflix dans d'autres pays tout ça ça
s'écoute notamment pour garder vos
séries us en avant première vous avez un
solide client 24 heures sur 24 sept
jours sur sept soit par email soit parti
shas donc ça aussi c'est cool et ça
fonctionne même en chine vous avez
jusqu'à 6 connexion simultanée entre vos
ordis votre téléphone et tutti quanti
une bande passante qui est illimité je
ne peux que vous recommander des cm2
gipn télécharger l'application vous
aimez le lien en bas dans la description
que vous ayez à ios ou android pour
venir sécuriser vous
sonné et croyez moi les questions de la
sécurité c'est important ça sera encore
plus dans les années à venir avec la
salle j ai pensé dit dès maintenant
regardez moi ce temps guérit faisait 30
degrés et vous êtes très très beau là
c'est plus vieux il fait un temps
horrible même les building sont dans le
brouillard
c'est pas tout ça mais bon ça ne
m'empêchera pas on va se parler
aujourd'hui de ce smartphone a mis 9
lite je voulais déjà présenté
aujourd'hui c'est le jour du test du
minadt flight à new york
mais avant toute chose on commence la
journée par se faire beau pas se brosser
les dents
faire du sport
[Musique]
petit déj et puis go new york
vraiment temps de merde aujourd'hui à
new york pluie autant hier il faisait 31
degrés il est très très chaud là
aujourd'hui c'est la pelure décision
lève sort il pleut l'otan est bien bien
bien buter un dégueulasse et bon basket
alors justement aujourd'hui je vous
parlais du smartphone de schumi qui
s'appelle le mineur flight 9000 places
est déjà présente et on l'a déjà vu le
jour on est à paris
tout ce qu'il faut pour être cool de se
faire un petit est aujourd'hui à new
york donc on en profite et on espère un
retour justement de ce petit mineur
flight voir quels sont ses atouts ses
inconvénients ce qui va ce qui va pas
mais dans un premier temps je pense
qu'il va falloir se trouvait un spot où
il ne pleut pas ça va être compliqué que
cette toute petite pluie ici
mais bon globalement débat la première
chaussure se produit ils ont des parlers
déjà lorsque je vous l'avais présenter
c'est la prison d'ain c'est un produit
que je trouve assez léger 179 g ça
marche plutôt pas mal ça c'est assez
cool prise en main bien lorsque vous
conseille quand même cette vie reprendra
demain plutôt qu'à une main pour éviter
les problèmes
à côté de ça il est protégé corning
gorilla glass 5 à l'avant à l'arrière ça
ça va ça fonctionne
le design me semble plutôt bien une fois
de plus je trouve que vous avez cette
espèce de petite encoche ici alors bon
ça malheureusement
on va peut être pouvoir est coupée ça
fait partie des design qu'on a cette
année sur ces typologies de smartphones
c'est pas hyper déconnant le design est
pas mal à ses actuelles a une fois de
plus près ce que vous recommander
protéger pour éviter la déconvenue
n'existe pas ici aux us des citrouilles
partout dans les vitrines autochtone on
monte la honda 7e avenue en décembre
dérisoire central park la other time
square la voilà c'est une petite baie de
new york en même temps maintenant ils en
ont profité pour nous parler de cet
écran alors vous avez un écran amoled
d'un écran sam sous je pas si vous le
savez mais dans le monde des écrans oled
samsung et lg régné en maître avec des
écrans qui sont vraiment d'excellente
qualité
la banque où on a un écran de 6,39
pouces se trouve moi franchement bien
bien calibré assez lumineux qui en plus
à venir lutter contre
la lumière bleue alors c'est vrai que je
ne sais pas trop rendu compte faire un
petit peu compliqué c'est ce que nous
dit en tout cas xiaomi au niveau des
specs nous annonce effectivement que cet
écran à venir en tout cas prendre soin
de vos yeux ça tombe bien c'est vrai
dans le bon sens
l'écran est correct à s'éliminer même si
vous avez beaucoup de lumière à
l'extérieur alors attention on n'est pas
sur un smartphone très haut de gamme
on est sur un smartphone milieu de gamme
et qui fonctionne bien et qui pour mon
toit pour le côté purement visionnage
est vraiment cool
si vous êtes déjà venu à new york aussi
vous le savez mais ici il ya alors c'est
lahoud qui a légalisé mais ces prêts
avec le thc je sais pas ce que c'est
comme truc mais ça sent la buzz dans la
rue quand vous vous baladez ses coûts
fixes
alors attention je vous le jeu
n'incitent pas à fumer c'est interdit
d'autant plus en france où il ya des
états aux us où l'on peut consommer du
thc
mais je crois ici mais ça semble un peu
que vous balader dans le plein times
square vous avez des familles il ya
plein de gens et ça sent la veut
toujours bizarre et giresse en janvier
devraient contradictions vous avez le
wild world ici sur la 7e avenue c'est à
dire qu'on est quasiment à times square
qui est juste au fond plein centre j'en
profite comme ça même pas vous faire une
petite visite donc là on va arriver sur
times square alors je sais pas si vous
connaissez si c'est un peu le coeur de
la ville côté grand tourisme vous avez
des très grands écrans de partout avec
de la pub alors l'intérêt de times
square c'est assez mitigé pour moi c'est
vraiment l'endroit juste où vous avez
des de la plume de la pub de la pub de
la pulse un endroit qui est extrêmement
éclairé même la nuit si vous regardez du
ciel si vous êtes en hélicoptère en
avion vous verrez beaucoup beaucoup de
lumière parce qu'il n'y a que la pub de
partout et là vous avez les doubles
comme quoi si vous voulez faire un petit
plaisir
cravate comme owen iweb en plein coeur
de times square avec des écrans de tous
les côtés de la pub de tous les côtés
c'est l'opulence les écrans c'est
l'opulence de la publicité s'est alors
vite mon fils il mais quand vous presse
à new york c'est quand même bien de
venir faire une balade par ici pour se
rendre compte
voilà regardez moi ce temps bien pourri
vous avez les building qui sont
complètement dans le brouillard pense
que lapointe coup l'a vu c'est pas trop
ça il me prépare même noël ici que
choisir votre père noël tout ce que vous
voulez le père noël a sion la cinquième
avenue pas ma grosse boutique spéciale
noël on est tout en haut de la 7e avenue
on a passé
thain score depuis longtemps et là on
arrive à central park qui est juste là
donc ici arbres écureuils sympa on va en
profiter pour quoi elle est justement de
performances et d'autonomie par rapport
à ceux mis 9 lite derrière les quand je
vous parle d'écureuil la petit écureuil
il y en a partout ici et ils sont pas
très sauvage mois la performance se
trouve pas mal sans être complètement
dingue vous avez un seul un dragon 710
dessus qui est couplé à 6 giga de ram
alors pour une utilisation compte tout
ce qui va être je dirais photos vidéos
regarder du contenu multimédia jouer à
des jeux pas trop lourd mais on
m'appelle j'y vous pouvez le faire
tourner dessus ça marchera parfaitement
bien c'est un smartphone qui va être
bien mais que vous n'avez pas pouvoir
venir le pousser dans ses retranchements
pour quelques parties de gaming ça ira
déjà parfaitement bien avoir les jeux
les plus puissants par les jeux les plus
performants mais pour revenir se marrer
avec son smartphone déjà comme ça c'est
plutôt pas mal l'autonomie n'est pas mal
avec une batterie de 4000 30 millions
paire eur et un chargeur de 18 watts
inclus directement dans la boîte
ça vous permet de l'utiliser pendant
deux jours alors ça ça dépend bien
évidemment de vos usages santé pense que
vous allez en faire si vous êtes très
gourmand ou très gourmande les deux
jours vous les aurez pas mais sur un
usage à taux courants vous l'aurez il
faut bien qu'une journée normalement
vous êtes tranquille un jour et demi si
par contre vous bombardez en jeu si vous
bombardez en photo ou en vidéo
à ce moment là l'autonomie ça va pas
durer tant que ça
mais par contre ce qui est cool c'est
qu'effectivement vous allez leur charge
est assez rapidement chez eux mais nous
avons une recharge de 0 à 40 3 % en 30
minutes
j'ai pas réussi à le quantifier de cette
manière là mais je trouve effectivement
si par exemple vous vous levez le matin
qui vous reste plus beaucoup de batterie
vous avez oublié de recharger et bien le
temps d'aller vous doucher vous préparez
vous pouvez passer effectivement 20
minutes très facilement vous le plus gai
et vous êtes reparti pour déjà un petit
moment qu'on attendait ce dock les
dakarois continue de petites balades
dans new york avec l'iphone flatte ou
fat iron
je me rappelle jamais du nom de ce menu
il est planqué ici on a un triple module
photo sur ce smartphone 48 mégapixels
soit ni annick 582 on en suit une caméra
de 8 mégapixels est un grand-angle 218
degrés et en finance et avec un
troisième capteurs ces 2 mégapixels quai
pour le mode portrait pour laisser
bloquer pour apporter la profondeur
alors bon déjà on va parler juste de la
caméra principale jusqu'à 28 méga pixels
qui fonctionne bien mais ce qui n'est
pas officiellement fait il met néanmoins
c'est celui qui aura le mieux vous
n'allez pas voir le plus de détails vous
n'allez pas voir le truc le plus ouf
mais ça fera des photos correctes
attention il n'est pas stabilisé donc
vraiment le stabilité sinon ça va
rapidement et de la guerrière quand vous
arrivez son grand angle vous allez
perdre un peu en termes de luminosité
dans l'ultra grand temps que vous allez
perdre aussi en termes de luminosité
ça fera le job sa traditionnelle a coûté
un peu des formes ans c'est pas parfait
c'est pas idéal
néanmoins pour ramener quelques bourdes
venir se faisait beaucoup lumière ça
fonctionne
le mode portrait et pas ouf mais
fonctionne le zoom
quant à lui fait le taf on a un gros
résultat en termes de photos fichiers
ok mais qui est pas complètement dingue
par contre qu'un truc qui est absolument
incroyable
je vais vous montrer c'est leur filtre
avec le ciel ça par contre c'est
extrêmement bleus font alors regardez
j'ai fait une photo c'est celle là on se
rend bien compte tout de suite le temps
est quand même relativement mieux ça
n'était pas très beau le ciel est gris
ça vous vous en douterez par contre on
va pouvoir rendre ça vachement plus
beaux et moi ça me touche ça me bluffe
la façon dont on peut faire croire tout
et n'importe quoi je vous mets un beau
temps voilà si vous voulez qu'il fasse
beau d'un coin new york on peut vous
rappelle quand même que le ciel est
comme ça tout de suite
c'est une photo que j'ai pris il ya cinq
minutes on peut aussi rajouter quelques
petits nuages voilà sur me faire croire
qu'il manque c'est nuageux un petit arc
en ciel qui vient de dessiner la cse
sweety c'est pas mal un petit ciel
éclats c'est hallucinant un petit
crépuscule voilà c'est le soir tombe
bien peu moins de lumière mais de très
jolies couleurs ou alors carrément un
petit coucher de soleil
et là franchement
regardez moi ça c'est quand même
vachement bluffant je vous rappelle que
le temps tout de suite c'est ça hein
c'est une photo qui était prise il ya
cinq minutes c'est exactement ça et ça
pour moi c'est absolument incroyable
alors le truc peut paraître extrêmement
gadget vous vous dites pourquoi est ce
que j'irai utiliser ça au final si on
réfléchit un peu la stratégie derrière
de xiaomi on est sur un smartphone qui
s'adresse à un public assez jeune qui a
partagé des photos sur les réseaux
sociaux lors il ya plein d'autres
chiffres mais celui-là extrêmement
bluffant pas en fait toujours halluciné
on est sur un smartphone quand les
ressources illégales ram 128 go de
stockage de 299 euros il ya une toute
une offre pendant le mois d'octobre chez
cdiscount à 269 euros d'ailleurs déjà
dit dans ma vidéo de présentation
pour plus de détails vous invite à aller
la retrouver il vous avez une deuxième
version qui est sis +128 j'ai mes notes
je ne connais pas les prix parker 6 +128
à 329 euros non qu'on instaure un
smartphone qui pas complètement trop
cher en tout cas et qui a plein de
belles fonctionnalités qui fonctionne
bien qui est sûre du milieu de gamme
milliers autres gadgets plutôt de milieu
de gamme quand même ce smartphone
d'entrée de gamme de milieu de gamme un
proche milieu de gamme on peut faire pas
mal de choses à des performances et de
l'autonomie c'est pas tout mais ça
marche la caméra c'est pas ou peu mais
ça fonctionne mais par contre le fait
justement et la syldavie vraiment dire
choisissez la cible instagram vous
faites des photos voulais partager
compte il faut quand même beaucoup de
lumière mais ça marche led de
notification qui n'est pas une led mais
qu' un logo de notification ses locaux
shiomi il va changer de couleur en
fonction la notification que vous allez
avoir bon sens a pas mal l'intérêt en
fait pour moi c'est lorsqu'il est posé
sur une table que vous êtes j'en sais
rien moi à la fac au travail au
restaurant ou peu importe
et bien volkova s'allumaient d'une
certaine couleur et ça vous dire à quel
type de choses vous avez un message en
appelle donc ça je trouve ça pas mal
c'est intéressant ça évite d'avoir la
petite led de notification un petit peu
standard ici il ya un côté un peu
différent et puis surtout le fait de
l'avoir intégré sur le logo xiaomi c'est
très malin d'ailleurs ce mois ci faisait
remarquer et je voulais dire autrefois
effectivement si on m'y a passé un pas
sur la france en tout cas peut-être sur
l'europe
le fait de mettre un logo xiaomi est pas
un logo micky en tout cas est moins
connu logo miclo associés pas mal c'est
me wade
bon c'est un peu standard c'est pas les
os le plus dingue c'est pas la surcouche
en tout cas qu'on aura la plus folle
mais bon ça fonctionne et notamment
dessus abordant le thème sombre l'idée
c'est que comme vous avez un pic ses
ailes noires qui va pixels et un second
écran oled et bien justement se
permettra d'économiser de la batterie
donc
pourquoi pas j'espère vous aurez
apprécié aussi cette petite balade dans
new york un petit est un petit peu
différent de son côté actuellement il ya
beaucoup de monde de tous les côtés
j'adore ces deux villes sa bouche
je vous invite vraiment si vous en avez
l'occasion si vous pouvez le faire à
venir la découvrir cette ville allait
juste complètement incroyable voilà sur
ce je vous laisse c'est la fin de ce
test vous invite à me dire tout ce que
vous en pensez en bas en commentaire et
se poser des questions pouvez y aller
sans se faisant brasse et puis je vous
dis à demain yahoo